so I'm going to talk about inference uh
from more or less a Quantum field Theory
point of view I'm going to attempt to uh
to make it very accessible and I think
one of the real problems for physics is
that Quantum field theory is not
accessible
enough uh so I've spent the last 20
years focused on
renormalization uh but I'm not going to
talk about that at all uh there's three
recent articles uh that uh talk about
I'm going to have to speed up um that
talk about the uh the relationship
between quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics and about the measurement
problem but they do so in terms of an
underlying ideas about Quantum field
Theory and specifically as if it's a
noisy signal analysis
formalism and I think that can make
contact with this Workshop in in the
sense that inference and machine
learning can be thought of as data
analysis toolboxes um so one can
approach the relationship between
quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics in so many different ways the
way I've chosen to do for the last few
years is partly through uh the idea that
nogo theorems tell us that quantum
mechanics is more than in some sense
classical mechanics and so um one
approach following on from that is to
think that we should uh try to construct
a more complete version of classical
mechanics add to it instead of trying to
add to Quantum Mechanics so that it's
more like classical mechanics and in the
Articles above uh I construct what I
call CM plus and that includes in the
first instance measurement Inc
compatibility so in algebraic terms
non-commutativity
you can use the pron bracket if you're
willing to use it in its full power you
can use the pron bracket to construct a
full algebra or noncommut algebra of
measurement operators measurement
observables within classical mechanics
it's sort of it's been straw manned
classic mechanics been straw manned so
that you cannot use these things just by
Fiat if you do do this then the next
thing you need to do is to introduce the
idea well is to recognize that Quantum
noise and thermal noise cannot be the
same thing within this new
structure you need to find some some
really solid difference and Quantum
field Theory actually has a solid
difference Quantum Noise Within uh
within Quantum field Theory can be
thought of as just the Loren invariant
component the vacuum is Loren invariant
and it it's so its noise in so far as
you're willing to accept that there's
noise there Isen variant and that for me
as a field theorist implies that we
should really think of CM plus as a
field Theory so a random field Theory
would be a terminology that can be used
but I'm not going to include into this
analyticity what I'm going to call
analyticity um which is a consequence of
the fact that quantum mechanics projects
to positive frequencies
which CM plus does not and I want to
keep them separate because I want to be
able to compare CM plus with quantum
mechanics Quantum field Theory and see
what the differences are and hence
perhaps learn something about that about
both uh and indeed this projection of
positive frequency is very similar to
what you find in Signal analysis where
there is uh the idea of an analytic
signal and a real signal uh essentially
as the positive frequency and the not
positive and an unconstrained frequency
okay so CM plus is a hbit space
formalism uh for noisy signal analysis
and in so far as it is a hbit space
formalism it can describe experiments
equally well as Quantum field
Theory and indeed for the
electromagnetic field in particular not
for all such things we can construct
isomorphisms linear isomorphisms between
Quantum electronic magnetism and what
I'm call CM plus
electromagnetism so this is not
quantization because it is isomorphisms
it's a much cleaner construction it's
not a replacement for for quantization
but it is an alternative I suggest is
useful to have in the
toolbox it's not a Panacea it's
statistically non-local this is this is
something that is going to have
consequences down the road as we try to
study what it might do okay so uh I sub
submitted this abstract to PR 5 weeks
ago and I've struggled to keep to it um
correlation not equal causality
obviously very naive sort of thing what
do we have to add to it caal modeling
does add something to it intervention in
particular gives us a means of talking
about causality uh in mathematics and
physics however we have generalized
probability and contextuality which
gives us similar Tools in a a framework
that is essentially algebraic as a whole
and in that sense I feel that it's more
unified obviously this is uh to people's
taste to some extent and from machine
learning we'll discover in the uh last
four slides whether or not I have
something interesting to
say um
so again there are so many things you
can pick out from causal modeling uh the
do notation so many people pick out that
well of course I should as well in any
case it seems connected to uh the uh the
state preparation that one has in
quantum mechanics so we have required uh
for a transformation is more or less you
take a dial you turn it to X there is
your I have will it so you could have
turned it into X1 X2 X3 you didn't you
turned it to X so DX equals x is
semantically different in that sense
from it happened that x equals x you
made no there was no uh will involved at
all but mathematically it's just the
same both of these constructions can fit
perfectly well into as models of the col
of
axium so um so we have experimental
protocols decree what will be done by
the experimenter the experimenter
typically is not free there there is is
a design of the experiment that says you
will choose random numbers if you choose
all zeros then you will have to do the
experiment again we can transform any
aspect of an experimental apparatus by
having enough dials each one of which is
connected to the internals of the
apparatus so that things
happen uh and afterwards however there's
just data in computer memory that is
what you are going to use you're going
to apply any algorithm that
works and you've done multiple
interventions and you keep track of what
interventions you've done to to obtain
that data so from a data analysis
perspective one thing we obviously do is
construct relative frequencies and for
that uh we just take construct a number
between Z and one but a rational number
uh and we can add those as long as we
don't double count to get a new relative
frequency we can add many of them uh so
long as we don't double count or emit
anything we'll get the number
one and uh well we have to keep track of
do counting an emission in one way or
another so historically the frequencies
came out of the 19th century the chog of
axioms followed that mathematics and if
it if it hadn't we'd be talking about
someone else's axioms I
suggest and then once we have the kums
then we can construct models for those
in terms of expected values for the
relative frequencies which in now real
numbers instead of rational numbers
perhaps we can talk about different
semantics so something like propensities
we can talk about the do semantics and
we can also construct linear algebraic
models for the com aums so when we
construct a uh NOP wrong thing I've just
gone forward a line that I didn't intend
to but I won't go back uh so when we
construct for frequencies uh then we
hope that those will come turn out to be
the same as what we had from uh from a
theory that we had written down
algebraically we could use compatible so
commutative operators to construct this
also gives us a positive number and so
by choosing the right State and the
right right projection operators we can
make this be the same as this
but also we can if we want to use
arbitrary so long as the Spectra the
spectrum of the operat no arbitrary
operators at y and x uh that give us the
same numbers as this but using
non-commutative operators and this in
fact is the mathematics of the collapse
of the wave function but just used to
construct a conditional probability or
indeed the top line just joint
probability so we have generalized
probability gives us ways to interpolate
between different contexts so if we do
find many relative frequencies and we
find um in many different context we
place a new context relative to uh an
earlier context then we can compute
expected values for new the new relative
frequencies and that's what we get out
of the linear algebra of quantum
mechanics in particular
incompatibility is a way of placing
contexts as non-trivial transformations
of other contexts
for quantum mechanics we can do that
straightforwardly because we can
generate Transformations instantly just
by using any Omission operator for CM
plus it's a little more difficult
because we only have a commutative
algebra uh but we can use the personal
bracket to construct the transformation
algebra direct transformation algebra
and that then we can use so long as we
don't STW man ourselves to construct
just the same algebra as we have from
quantum mechanics or Quantum field
theory in
fact so I'm going to talk about the B
inequalities with apologies um but
entirely from a field theoretic point of
view this is an experiment from the 1995
this is page 60 from
gregoris thesis it's a really nice
diagram from my point of view partly
because up here
oh can't I do have to go back from that
one up here he talks about a pump he
pumps the electromagnetic field as I
will say he doesn't shovel particles in
he pumps the electromagnetic
field then uh he also is extremely clear
about what he's going to store he's
going to store the time at which events
happen no particles in this at all in
this description it's not that you can't
have a particle description but if you
do then you're going to have quite a
compromised idea of a particle in order
to do so but from a field Theory point
of viewa you're pumping a noisy field
it's actually perfectly
straightforward for
me um so he also again with the uh the
wrong
key so he also stores which of these
Avalanche photo diodes actually had the
signal went from some lowend I have a
beautifully shaky hand which is exactly
as shaky shaky as the uh as the display
there and when when an event happens
then that's the time which Gregor stores
and at the same time he also stores the
random bit generated value that has set
the uh the electrooptic modulator here
which is changing the polarization on on
a sort of megahertz scale uh so that uh
we can say something about
causality it needs to be that fast in
order for this to be uh to be a good
test of that on the other hand this
experiment is is much simpler than the
2016 experiments and so I don't don't
want to use that for display so here's
the actual data uh my my computation of
of this uh this is 15,000 event oh again
15,000 events and you can see the
coincidence there within about 1 nond
all of these 15,000 events total across
all of these plus or minus 3
nond uh and uh and indeed you can see
that many of the events are green and
yellow in the color scream I've used
here where the red is the diagonal the
blue is the lower diagonal and the
yellow and the green the other two
diagonals and that green and yellow
is actually uh sign signifies the
violation of inequalities if you turn
that diagram on the on its side you
slice it 100 100 times in this way you
can compute a histogram of count that
counts each of the 16 different types of
events you can add up those numbers and
then you can put that into by now
completely standard calculation of
violation of ab in
equalities so all we've done here is we
have a completely classical set of data
we've applied a completely classical
algorithm and out of that we've got a
number at which point classical particle
physics says no this is not any good we
cannot have
this so what I'm going to point to you
is that in quantum mechanics we actually
use measurement compatiability the
non-commutativity of the algebra
measurements to uh to model violation
and B inequalities this is something
You' find in the literature since about
1980 in classic mechanics as usual we
don't have measurement in compatibility
we stra man ourselves so we're not
allowed to do
it one response to this is well you can
read what comes next to as well is we
can say that classical mechanics is
computationally
incomplete quantum mechanics is more
that classic mechanics so um we can use
the pron bracket to add measurement of
compatibility into classic mechanics
giving us CM plus so it's
computationally as complete as qu
Quantum field Theory it's just a more
effective thing than C than classical
mechanics itself so I focused on on
non-commutativity there's clearly a
whole pilot about nonlocality for qu of
fields micro causality asserts that
locality is closely associated with
measurement in compatiability and indeed
there's a a version of that which is
called har Duality which really makes it
identical Quantum fields are however are
much less like classical particle
physics than they are like the heat
equation or any kind of non-equilibrium
thermodynamics so those kinds of equ
things do depend on the boundary
conditions once you've set the boundary
conditions the whole system will equil
equilibrate to the boundary conditions
so completely different from what one
expects for a particle physics for a
particle physics
intuition and uh and temperature
measurements in qu in uh classical what
effectively is CM plus as far as I'm
concerned are jized for measurement in
Quantum field Theory approximately local
but they are not point-like this is
something that is standard in the in the
more mathematical Lit Literature on
Quantum field Theory so if you're
willing to go with me on the idea that
Quantum field Theory can be thought of
usefully as a noisy signal analysis
formalism and I suggest that we do
introduce measurements this is a
measurement Theory because quantum
mechanics is measurement Theory and
indeed Quantum field theory is about a
measurement operator value distribution
which we use to construct a measurement
operator which I'm going to index with
something which I'm going to label F and
I'm going to click through to the next
slide to assume it again
um where those two in fact I'm going to
go back so that I don't distract myself
um where the the the functions f and g
they're called test functions in the
mathematical literature they're called
window functions much more graphically
in the signal analysis
literature these also can be thought of
as the readme functions if you're a
computer programmer you need to know how
you got the data Inu in computer memory
that the measurement gave you
so those describe where and when and how
big what shape and anything else the
experiment is going to need strictly
speaking ought to be in the um in that
description so now forly in Quantum
field Theory an F measurement and a g
measurement which is how I term them are
if those are space likee or causally
separated then they're compatible
operators in which case this expression
get the right button is a correlation
coefficient it's just as you'd expect in
classical statistics classical
probability Theory but if they are Tim
like or lightlike separated then they
are incompatible and this construction
has an imagining
component which I suggest we can think
of as a bookkeeping from an engineering
point of
of bookkeeping for the consequences of
quantum noise for this particular pair
of
measurements now we do have to work with
um causal correlations at time like
separation we have to have models for
that what we use for that is the
collapse of the wave function it's just
a mathematics for constructing a joint
probability for constructing correlation
coefficients this is obviously a way of
well I turn perit in the third of the
papers I decided at the top uh a um a
construction of a a joint probability
construction and this is a way of
rethinking the uh measurement problem I
find and some people have also thought
so um so what I think Quantum field
Theory does um is it um oh sorry for for
for this uh C CM plus electromagnetism
it's empirically equalent to because
it's isomorphic to Quant quanti
electromagnetism
the F measurement and the g measurement
are always compatible so you haven't got
the quantum field Theory yet but you use
the plal bracket to introduce the
transformation algebra and use it in a
general way General enough way that it
gives you all of the operators you'd
expect in Quantum field Theory and you
can do it it's isomorphic it's published
anyway
um and uh so finally I think we can
think of this as Quantum field Theory
folding into the
formalism uh just the quantum noise
aspect of causality this is something
it's reasonable to do but it's also
something you don't necessarily have to
do you could make a conventional choice
of using CM plus em if that's more
helpful if it's good to keep your
Quantum noise
separate okay so uh six months ago
because of machine learning and CA of
modeling and because of ranky damn it um
I really started to wonder whether
physics really needs to be about more
than
probability because um machine learning
seemed to me doesn't necessarily try to
classified data inter reference classes
it doesn't necessarily count
anything so machine learning algorithm
just takes a data item in its initial
State and constructs a state after that
and that need not be any kind of
linearity or Guided by probability
distribution probability Theory at
all so relative frequency just not part
of this whole
thing and on the other hand there are
certainly generative large language
models typically are constrained to be
consistent with probability it makes
them much more more uh understandable
and that's part I think of why people
have adopted an interest in them because
they feel that it can be understood at
some
level so if an algorithm is consistent
with probability I suppose we might call
it basian machine learning because it
does try to keep does make it more
understandable but I do wonder whether
it's better it is might be better to uh
to keep very clear in one's mind as to
whether you want to go that way or the
other way not saying you shouldn't go
one way or the other just it is
something to keep in mind
okay so I'm going to go back for a
moment to the uh to the data we had
before this is out out 100 NCS each way
instead of three NCS each way you can
see that um in the center is the the
narrow coincidences beautifully
engineered I mean getting that to work
years of research years of uh
constructing the experiment but you can
see there's also this other uh narrower
sorry broader band at around about plus
orus 209 seconds Gregor didn't know that
was there if he had he would have had to
spend an extra well he might have taken
a day to realize what it was but he
might have spent two years more figuring
out what the hell was causing that
excuse my French um so there's something
about EXT about debugging the apparatus
that would require him to go back in and
say what could be causing this problem
what do I have to change to make the
problem smaller or larger if I can
figure out how to make it larger I
probably can just say ah change the
direction somehow this is something that
you really debugging is is very causal
in in this sense but also I'm saying it
can be can be addressed classically so
long as you're willing to put into this
uh Plank's constant very seriously and
model it as a classical Loren invariant
noise mathematically is isomorphisms
really make me think that I I don't have
to do the same thing for every
experiment I can just say isomorphism to
you of course there will be exceptions
I've no no out and there's another thing
I would like to know about uh about this
experiment and that is this this
10-second period that he collected data
for yes lots of data beautiful it's
practically at equilibrium in the sense
of it being time translation invariant
in a c grained way it's not time
translation invariant if you just look
at this this particular event here
because that is a signal going bang not
at all at fine grade scale but this is
still
thermodynamics a gas doesn't have
equilibrium the T milus line meter
scale so here you turn on the power
there very few events at the beginning
you think yourself well well what happen
here will the violation of bell INE
equality
precede the uh the uh the events
actually happening somehow will it
happen later how fast will it be will it
be will it take will this time period
from lots of events to lots of events
coincidence in green and yellow will
will that be enough time for light to go
backwards and forwards 50 times or will
it be enough time for the like to go
back and forwards 0.1 times there's a
big difference between those two things
huge difference and yet this doesn't Pro
that at
all again you need to have the same
apparatus as he's got or something very
similar and you need to be probing this
aspect of this now it I've just talked
about um the uh this turning on the
power and off but of course any
modulation will do and you would like to
try different modulations see what kinds
of nonlinearity there are so if if there
is Ser serious nonlinearity you may find
that the b in equality is is satisfied
uh very much faster or slower so this is
all well okay last slide um it does seem
to me that if the world's always
changing so when Gregor finished his PhD
he went away that laboratory space that
apparatus was gone as soon as as
possible in comes a new student uses the
same Optical table and constructs their
thing so anything longer than 5 years is
not going to happen if you want 2,000
years of data well you can't get that
even in cosmology you um so there's this
interplay between intervention and
measurement results it seems to be much
more interactive the debing process
could be described formally but we
don't and I'm not saying we must but it
does seem to me that uh one could say
well quantum mechanics is not is not
empirically adequate you cannot describe
this decision and game theoretic aspect
of the of the what we're
doing and uh the final thing measurement
of compatibility and than constant uh
can be classical as well as Quantum so
uh this is just to say if you want to do
causal modeling absolutely classically
so long as when it's necessary Neary you
put in a good Lenin variant description
of with planks constants the amplitude
of the of the noise
then you can model everything
classically now I'm not saying anything
of this this doesn't change from
Computing at all for example you have
your apparatus you have you have
Gregor's experiment he designs the
experiment he puts it all together he
runs it the data doesn't care how I
describe it if I use CM Plus or quantum
Quantum elector it doesn't
matter what does matter is the theory
guides what you think is going to be an
interesting experiment to start to
construct there's an element of of the
human will at the scale of design and
implementation of the
apparatus there is no none of my will or
Gregor re's will is involved at the 25
kiltz no 40 khz scale of each individual
event in there the reason those events
happen
is because you've used an avalanche
photo diet which you've deliberately
used because it exhibits events you do
not use
rocks rocks just well you know unless
unless of course you have some really
sophisticated deder analysis out of out
of the Rock and uh you use very specific
kind of rock which is just as specific
as the materials you use for the a diet
I'm 25 and a half minutes
in thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much Peter W was very very
interesting U another fly in the
ointment no no taking a fly
out so um any questions before we open
up the floor for our close
thank Peter thank you that was really
interesting and I'm just I might have
missed it so maybe I'm I'm I'm really
collapsing things is much too far but
for your last Point here about Quantum
noise and its consequence being modeled
classically is is that because what
matters to the Dynamics of the classic
of the objects we can we already chose
to treat classically is because those
Dynamics are sensitive to things like
two-o functions of quantum fluctuations
are which we can then presumably at
least under many conditions replace with
a corresponding classical uh object or
is or is that is that missing more of
the structure that you had in mind I'm
wondering this last part in particular
we do that all the time as a convenience
uh when trying to model things on
admittedly classical computers we we'll
we we'll we'll initialize a simulation
by matching the statistics of two point
correlation functions even though we're
going to then evolve them perfectly CL
classically but we think they had a in
some sense capturing a kind of quantum
mechanical boundary something like that
I is there more than that was that
reasonable analogy there there is um the
um the way I think about this is for one
thing correlations at space likee
separation you can consider it
classically because the operators do not
commute do commute at Tim like
separation they don't commute but we
still have non we still have
correlations we need to
model so the way we model that is use
collapse but as far as the classical
physics is concerned it's just you use
commuting operators to model that so in
the signal analysis sort of framework
it's extreme ly it's it's really quite
natural to do that but the analyticity I
mentioned on the second slide is
critical to whether you want to use the
mathematics of quantum field Theory or
not because analyticity is
mathematically so beautiful you don't
want to throw that away at all but on
the other hand if you're doing signal
analysis maybe the cost of having 100
million
collapses in the mathema you just in the
model might would overturn the advantage
of using anity a quick followup um for
that that was very helpful uh even just
the gesture right
to and I not a wick rotation no I I I I
was I won't even make the joke but for
for that have you have you already
thought about things like the Leed gar
inequality which as you may know is a
bell-like inequality but for correlate
correlations of measurements on a single
system over time that sounds like that
should might be a way to break what
otherwise looks like an isomorphism but
you might have thought about all that as
well I I I'm just going to say to you
but it's isomorphic so anything that
Quantum Quantum field Theory can model
can be modeled by a different model or
what looks like a different model but
really the the the isomorphism is is is
completely nonlocal because it is a
projection to positive frequency and so
I it just in some sense it puts you
still an interpretive mess as far as but
nonetheless it's just an alternative
it's a different way of looking at it uh
and and it's significantly different I
think and like I said on the first slide
in in the in the pale gray um this I
think does give away to rethink
renormalization as well as
rethink the measurement
Theory
thanks Chris and then or just that you
had this broader band oh and you called
it an artifact so I was just wondering
you know that it's an artifact do you
assume it's an artifact
well I call it an artifact because um
partly because Gregor didn't know it
existed before I pointed it out to him
10 years ago um but
it's it's not clear it's not clear to me
what the explanation for it is if I knew
what the explanation was then I perhaps
would be properly Justified calling it
an artifact this is the only thing I
noticed from the all
right but I know that chemistry you know
what's artifact for one could be found
20 years by another oh this is actually
the real thing most interesting that
this that this indeed is completely new
physics and it will transform everything
but it's more likely that it's an artif
yeah Chris yeah so very curious the I
know you didn't have a chance to go into
a lot of the details but I was curious
about exactly what the Isom isomorphic
structures are that you're so if they're
both just Hilbert spaces there's one
sense in which
it's could be trivial but there might be
more structures on the Hilbert space
that you're mapping into one another and
similar to Dave's question I was
wondering just like you know think of
the standard properties you think of the
quantum vacuum like the re leader
theorem how is that modeled in cm plus
what you can do is you if if you
construct the quantum F the
electromagnetic Quantum field theory in
terms of uh creation and Annihilation
operators then there is an involution
that you can construct which allows you
to construct in terms of the same
creation of anation operator is an
operator that commutes everywhere so
instead of taking instead of the F
measurement and the g measurement the
commutator being a function of the the
FNG a linear function of the FNG instead
of that you find that the commutator of
this new m f f measurement and G
measurement is zero so the involution
does the job but the
involution uh has a Time reversal in it
and that's
non-local so uh it's it's a very very
simple construction uh if if I was
giving an hourong Court talk then it
would be in there uh and in one in one
slide it's uh it's quite simple but did
you have a quick followup so I still
don't understand how like the
entanglement properties of the quantum
vacuum would be mapped into the way
you're describing the quantum effects
due to the classical noise well you now
have this new mathematics and you you
will be free to interpret it in
whichever way you like now negative
frequencies of course could be
interpreted as
retroality but on the other hand it
doesn't necessarily have to be
interpreted that way just as there's
different interpretations you can have
of the quantum mechanics mathematics you
can have different interpretations in
this sort of way it's a freefor
all great thank you so much Peter thank
you
okay